now because the nets are literally  switching every screen on in off the  ball  so you're one on one all the time you're  never getting two defenders on the ball  order got his feet set cannot knock it  down johnson defending there remember he  gives it up playmaker harden nets by  five  and there's kaminga now curry with the  switch on to harden and james harden  goes to work  pounding it  harden and curry kicks him curry lays  out and  tucks the sideline with his shoulder  seven to shoot brooklyn ball side out  well this is great defense by curry who  is an underrated defender he's gotten a  lot better and james harden literally  just dribbling the air out of the ball  right there that is not the offense that  steve nash wants also the help defense  all those guys boxes and elbows helping  curry out no not a lot of lanes there  for hard to go great team defense and  individual defense of the warriors  durant back on the floor mills as well  he comes up short